so if you want to find the sine of half
of an angle what you can do is if you
know the cosine of the full angle all
you have to do is substitute it here in
this formula so we're gonna be using the
unit circle using angles that we're
familiar with like the 30 45 60 90 and
multiples of those cosines same thing if
you want to find half of the angle say
like twenty two point five you could use
cosine of 45 which is one that we know
on the unit circle the same thing with
tangent and you can see has two
different formats here that you can use
so there's a question sometimes it comes
up about this plus or minus and we'll
talk about that in a minute whether to
know whether you use the positive or the
negative so we'll just hold on to that
for a minute so let's go over here are
some examples so here we're gonna find
out what's the secant of half of theta
one half theta well first thing I'm
going to do is I'm just going to
complete this right triangle by finding
the hypotenuse using Pythagorean theorem
okay so we've got that now we don't have
a formula for secant of the half angle
but we have cosine and we know that
cosine is seeking our reciprocals of one
another so this is going to be one over
the cosine of theta divided by two okay
which equals okay now in this case we
have the square root of one plus cosine
of theta which over here you can see
cosine is adjacent over hypotenuse
that's eight tenths which is four-fifths
if we reduce all divided by two so
that's basically yet but now you're
going to want to do some arithmetic to
simplify that so here let me see if I
can show you that so it's 1 over 1 is 5
over 5 plus 4 over 5 would give you 9
over 5 okay divided by Q which is like
multiplying by 1/2 okay so this is 1
over the square root of 9 divided by the
square root of 10
okay and if we take the reciprocal that
equals the square root of 10 over the
square root of 9 which is 3 so there we
go we have an exact answer okay now this
one you can see this would be in the
first quadrant X is positive Y is
positive if we take half of that
okay half that angle you're still going
to be in the first quadrant the cosine
is still positive this is going to be
positive square root n over three
remember we're talking about the plus or
minus
okay now this one cotangent of theta
divided by two tangent of theta divided
by two we can use this formula here but
cotangent is the reciprocal of tangent
so we're just going to flip that over so
this is the sine of theta over one minus
the cosine of theta sine of theta we
know is opposite over hypotenuse so
that's six over 10 and one minus the
cosine of theta which is eight over 10
okay adjacent over hypotenuse if we
multiply the numerator and denominator
by 10 just to clear these denominators
if I distribute I get six 10 minus 8 so
I'm just distributing and that gives you
6 divided by 2 which equals three okay
now let's go to this one here next we
want to simplify this expression square
root of 1 plus cosine 4x divided by 2 so
which one of these formulas does that
look like plus so it looks like this one
so it's cosine half angle formula so
what this is going to be we're just
going to substitute theta in for theta
here on the left those are identical so
we have cosine of 4x divided by 2 of
course 4 / - those reduce so this is
just going to be the cosine of 2x okay
so we simplified we condense that using
the half angle formula ok last two
examples we want to find the sine of 112
degrees in 30
what's that symbol minutes right and
remember there's 60 minutes in a degree
so this is really like saying a hundred
and twelve point five degrees this is a
half degree okay so now this is not one
that we know on the unit circle so we're
gonna go to our sine half angle formula
and we recognize that this is half of
225 one that we are familiar with on the
unit circle so let's go ahead and use
the sine half angle formula
and let's just look at this here for a
moment on the unit circle so 225 is
right here this sign positive or
negative in the third quadrant it's
negative so does that mean we use the
negative well a hundred and twelve point
five degrees is going to be here in the
second quadrant sine is positive in the
second quadrant so we're interested in
where this angle is not where this angle
is so we're not interested in where 225
is we're interested where 112 and 1/2 is
and sine is positive in that second
quadrant so we're going to use a
positive one that's an important point
to pay attention to you so positive one
minus the cosine of 225 divided by two
and then if we simplify this let's see
here let me make a little bit more room
cosine of 225 equals square root two
over two okay and that's going to be
negative so this is one minus a negative
square root 2 over 2 divided by two okay
now what you can do is you can multiply
the numerator in the denominator by two
because that's just like multiplying
this whole expression by one and if you
distribute you clear the denominator so
this is going to be 2 plus root 2 over 4
you can split this up into two square
roots square root of the numerator is
square root of the denominator so that's
going to be square root of 2 plus square
root of 2 all over the square root of 4
but square root of 4 is 2 so there's our
final answer now you might be thinking
why couldn't we just do the center
calculator I know this is 112 point five
degrees sine of 100 12.5 and you're done
right but what this is it's an exact
answer just like when we use the unit
circle with the square root 3 over 2 and
the square root 2 over 2 those are exact
values not approximations like the
calculator is going to give you so
that's what these formulas do for you
give you that exact value ok last
example cosine of 3 PI over 8 this is
half of 3 PI over 4 so we go to our
cosine half angle formula we're going to
put in 3 PI over 4 and we're going to
simplify so I'll just show you that one
really quick here
so cosine of 3 PI over 4 is going to be
ok so this is the square root of cosine
3 PI over 4 it's negative root 2 over 2
divided by 2 again we're going to
multiply the numerator and denominator
by 2 so it gets this gives us 2 minus
root 2 all over 4 take the square root
of course the square root of 4 is 2 and
so we just get the square root of 2
minus the square root of 2